Comme nous le dit
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ça n'a pas trop changé,juste ?
Ah! oui, le grand grand,
grand studio 42.
- Dominique Michel était déjà
Canada en 1973 lors
de l'ouverture du studio 42.
DOMINIQUE MICHEL, comédienne
- L'immensité de ce studio-là,
alors ça, ici, on était bien
parce qu'on respirait puis
on était dans le grand studio,
puis ça... on dirait que
ça nous poussait à être
peut-être plus présent puis...
on travaillait très fort.
On savait que ça, ça coûtait
cher, le studio 42!
Il ne veut pas point, pantoute!
- Durant cinq décennies,
la reine du "Bye bye"
a accompagné les téléspectateurs
en direct de ce studio mythique.
- Des fois, je partais
en courant comme pour aller
me changer. Je me changeais pas.
Je courais derrière les rideaux
du studio et je me changeais.
S'il y avait des techniciens
derrière, ils m'ont vue toute
nue, ils m'ont vue me rhabiller,
ils m'uis là,
j'arrivais... ah!
Parce qu'on n'a le temps
d'aller aux loges, là,
parce qu'on était "live".- Moi,?
- Oui!
- C'est le téléthéâtre "Papa",
présenté aux "Beaux Dimanches"
en 1973, qui a inauguré
le studio. Capablelir
600 spectateurs, le 42
a hébergé les plus grandes
émissions de variété.
- On y va, tout le monde!
- "Allô Boubou".......
- ... "Star d'un soir"
ou "La Fureur" ont fait
les beaux jours de
la télévision française au pays.
Un studio qui a étn
de l'évolution technologique
et de la société au cours
des 50 dernières années.
PIERRE BEAUCAGE, directeur
technique à la retraite
- On a commencé ici, le studio,
le son était en mono, l'image
était 4/3, c'était uniquement
des hommes qui étaient sur
les plateaux à la technique
et puis au scénique.
Aujourd'hui, on a quasiment
30 à 40 % de femmes.
- Que ce soit pour
"Tout le monde en parle"
ou pour les soirs de gala,
le studio 42 est resté
jusqu'à la fin un lieu
de tournage d'exception.
Ce soir, "Les Enfants de
la télé" sera la dernière
émission à y être enregistrée.
ANDRÉ ROBITAILLE, animateur
- J'étais enfant, puis
je regardais les émission ici.
D'être ici, aujourd'hui,
pour la dernière émission
enregistrée au 42...le sentimen,
c'est privilège.
- Désormais, c'est
au studio A de la Nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Ca
que seront filmés les grands
rendez-vous télévisuels.
FRANCOIS MESSIER, DG Productions
et Sports, Radio-Canada
- On a voulu bâtir sur
ce qu'on avait acquis dans
le 42. Je pense que la sonorité
est un élément extrêmement
important, mais également
toute la flexibilité
qu'on est capable d'apporter
à l'ensemble de nos productions.
- C'est une page de
notre histoire qui se tourne,
et c'est à Dominique Michel
que revient le mot de la fin.
- Ça, c'est vrai, c'est
mon dernier reportage
au studio 42.